amyotrophic Lateral sclerosis
Shortened to Als is a neurodegenerative disease
Which usually begins in adulthood and Advances rapidly?
It's characterized by the deterioration and loss of both upper and lower
motor Neurons as
the motor Neurons stop sending signals the Muscles weaken leading to Paralysis
When the muscles in the diaphragm are paralyzed this can be fatal. There is no known cure for Als
For most people the cause of their lS is unknown, but some people inherit the disease from their parents
By studying the genes that are altered in these patients
scientists have pinpointed processes in the neurons that might be causing als
It's too early to [know] which of these altered processes are a result of the disease and which could be a cause
But it's clear that they affect many different aspects of the motor neuron function
Let's start in the cell body here proteins that are not transported into the nucleus build up in the cytoplasm
Errors in the systems that build up and break down proteins also cause other
[Misfolded] proteins to accumulate
The different proteins can then aggregate and can become toxic to cells in Several ways
For example they can damage mitochondria the cell's power generators
Mitochondrial damage can lead to oxidative stress which can trigger breaks in the dNA of the cell
Als seems to affect Dna repair processes as well
When Dna breaks are poorly repaired it ultimately contributes to the death of the neuron?
the cells Transport Machinery can also be damaged
For example [als] affected neurons often have problems
Transporting rnA
proteins and
vesicles
Both in the cytoplasm and along the neurons axon these vesicles containing [Pourtant] cell signaling molecules called neurotransmitters
If these can't be moved along the axon or released the neuron can't send messages to its target cells
damage to the
cytoskeleton can also cause the Axon to retract [if]
This happens the Axon can no longer connect to the muscle nearby and can no longer signal the muscle to contract
other cell types can also be involved in als
Oligodendrocytes which electrically insulate the axon and [provide] support to the motor neuron don't work in people with Als
reduced uptake of
Neurotransmitters by astrocytes can lead to over activation of the receptors at the synapse and death of the neuron
Finally astrocytes and Microglia can produce factors that protect or [damaged] motor neurons
Neuronal death occurs when excessive damaging factors are produced
Further research is needed to find out which of these many processes caused the motor neuron degeneration seen in als patients
Targeting new drug therapies at those processes might lead to a treatment for this incurable disease